this video is sponsored by nordvpn and
will begin right after a short message
do you use the internet don't lie to me
i know you do
did you know that anytime you're online
someone could be
watching everything you're doing
including when you're making a purchase
filling out location information or
checking out a zelda video online
oh if there were only a quick easy and
affordable way to mask your ip address
giving you complete privacy and
protection when you browse the internet
actually there is thanks to the buddies
at nordvpn sponsoring this video
old uncle bandits got you covered by
using the link located in the
description below or
using the code nintendo bandit when
checking out you can take advantage of
this special deal and get four months
for free with the purchase of a two-year
plan
once again follow the link in the
description below or use the code
nintendo banner when checking out but
hurry this offer is only good for a
limited amount of time
and now on to the video
previously on masked nintendo bandit
have you ever wondered about where the
triforce was in breath of the wild
it's no secret that the legendary
artifact is the pinnacle and most
recognizable symbol of the legend of
zelda
so why was it not in the series latest
title breath of the wild
not including the triforce seems like a
deliberate choice given its impact on
the rest of the games in the series
could it be that the triforce wasn't
present due to a greater plot line
coming in the breath of the wild sequel
that will include the golden artifact
could it be that the triforce will
return to hyrule
okay is everybody done cringing over the
quality of my older
videos take a moment if you need to i
know i did anyway what i just showed you
is an older theory of mine that covers
where the triforce might have been in
the events of breath of the wild
you know what i did not cover in the
video though the fact that the triforce
is not present
in breath of the wild in fact i state
quite plainly at the start of the video
that the triforce just isn't in the game
at all
but little did i know that that's
actually a pretty debated fact among the
fan base
oh but don't worry the comments brought
it to my attention so on that note i've
decided like a year and a half later to
bring the long anticipated sequel to
that theory
now this video will be covering why i
believe the triforce is nowhere to be
found in the game and isn't going
to cover where i think instead the
triforce was
because that was kind of the point of
the other video if you're interested in
that theory though i will link to it in
the description below but just be
prepared
i was still pretty new to all this so
it's kind of rough in some parts
anyway let's get into it shall we first
let's talk about what we know the
triforce is
in contrast to what appears on the back
of zelda's hand in breath of the wild
the triforce is a physical relic that
grants wishes
it does possess the ability to
temporarily lose its physical form and
fuse with a holder making that iconic
yet in this case confusing
mark of the triforce on the back of that
user's hand although we've only seen
this happen when the triforce is split
into its three separate pieces of power
wisdom and courage and never when it's a
completed whole in fact in a link to the
past
ganon actually legitimately possesses
the entire triforce
but upon his defeat it's revealed that
he was not infused with the triforce but
rather was keeping the pieces in a
chamber located behind the room where
you battle
i happen to think that this is simply
because the completed triforce does not
fuse
we have also seen the complete process
that takes place when someone pieces the
triforce together and actually uses it
as in makes a wish in the wind waker at
the end of the game ganondorf
successfully finds tetris
zelda and link and at this point all
three pieces that were residing in their
hosts
automatically leave their hosts because
they can sense the other pieces are
nearby
the two pieces from lincoln zelda meet
ganondorf's and reform the completed
three-piece triforce in front of
everyone
but then as fans will recall ganondorf
is caught supervillain monologuing and
the king of hyrule actually touches the
relic before he can
making a wish that hyrule would drown
once and for all and with it the relics
of the past including ganondorf and
himself
after this selfless wish the triforce
flies into the air and
splits again and in the follow-up games
of the adult timeline the triforce is
never to be seen again
it's almost like the triforce splits
itself after use to prevent misuse or
overuse of its omnipotent
power where it goes after it splits here
is of course a mystery
the most common theory for this being
that it returns to the sacred realm but
that's besides the point you see problem
number one with the idea that zelda
possesses the complete triforce in
breath of the wild
is that it doesn't line up with the
triforce's proven patterns of behavior
that we just discussed
like the fact that it's never been seen
to reside in an individual in its
completed form or the fact that it will
split apart after use
in breath of the wild whatever power is
residing inside zelda
shows the entire symbol of the triforce
on the back of her hand which we've
never seen happen with the actual
triforce
and doesn't leave or depart after zelda
uses her powers
no fewer than three times in the game
once to seal ganon inside the castle
wants to give link the light arrows and
wants to seal ganon completely
secondly the triforce's powers don't
line up with what zelda's powers are
shown to do in the game
as i mentioned before the triforce is a
wishing machine
a relic i mean because of this it is
considered to be
all-powerful and is referred to as the
ultimate power in skyward sword and as
such has been the desire and catalyst
for countless wars and battles and
assassination attempts that span
more than the entirety of the zelda
timeline on the protectors of the
triforce known as the royal family and
the family's ancestor the goddess hylia
herself
in breath of the wild zelda's powers are
unlocked through an intense emotional
state like some sort of power up and can
perform
many different feats such as a huge
cleansing blast of light that results in
the abolition of ganon's melis and
destruction of machinery that previously
was running on malice granting link the
light arrows and ultimately sealing
calamity ganon away for at least another
ten thousand years or so
right off the bat you can see that none
of this aligns with what you would
expect from a relic that grants
wishes but rather aligns with her
already seen powers from previous games
like when she held ganon back with light
in ocarina of time or when she
fired light arrows in twilight princess
and wind waker the majority of her
powers shown in breath of the wild are
actually just rehashes from her
previously shown abilities
from previous zelda games and don't
really have anything to do with the
ultimate power
known as the triforce so pattern wise
and power wise zelda's powers have
really nothing to do with the triforce
except for the symbol that briefly
appears on her hand but rather have
everything to do with powers she's
already been shown to have
except for one in particular her sealing
power
so the final question remains if zelda
doesn't possess the entire triforce in
breath of the wild
where exactly did her never before seen
sealing power come from
the answer is most likely from the sages
you see
sealing ganon is a trope that's kind of
been done several times in the past
namely in ocarina of time when after
ganon is defeated by link with the aid
of zelda she calls upon the sages to
seal him away
it's important to note that at this
point the triforce of courage was with
link the triforce of wisdom was with
zelda and the triforce of power was
still with ganondorf
meaning the sealing power is not tied to
the power of the triforce at all
but rather to the sages in breath of the
wild the sages are nowhere to be found
well almost there is a brief mention of
the possible reincarnation of a sage on
satori mountain known as
satori but not only is he deceased at
this point but the title of sage used
here could just simply mean protector of
the mountain and not
holy sage like it used to either way i
said the sages were almost nowhere to be
found because
one of them their leader in fact has a
living descendant we see
all the time can you guess who it is
yeah it's none other than princess zelda
herself
who in ocarina of time is shown to be
the seventh sage and their leader since
the other sages are nowhere to be found
in the game
why wouldn't their collective ceiling
power now reside in zelda
the last remaining sage it actually
makes a lot of sense when you think
about it this way
and i think completely explains away the
idea that zelda's power comes from the
triforce
it doesn't it comes from a combination
of her ancient powers and the sealing
power of the sages
the triforce symbol on the back of her
hand is most likely just
that a symbol since it is after all also
the symbol of the goddesses and
generally used to depict what is good
and holy and righteous in zelda games
it also makes appearances in clothing
and beautiful wall art but nobody says
that's the triforce right
okay jokes aside that was ultimately
just my theory about why the triforce is
not present in breath of the wild and we
don't actually have it in writing
anywhere but what do you guys think
if you previously thought zelda
possessed the complete triforce or maybe
you still do
or something else entirely let me know
in the comments below thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed the
video please consider dropping a like
below to get the truth spread around on
youtube and if you enjoy this kind of
nintendo content
maybe smash that subscribe button to
stick around it's free
also huge thanks to my supporters who i
would not be able to do
any of this without if you watching want
to give old bandit a holiday gift or
maybe just help the next video come to
life
feel free to press that join button
below any of my videos or follow the
links to my patreon in the description
below
also there are now less than 20 days
left to claim your limited edition 100
000 subscribers special merch so be sure
to check it out and use the code
happy100 for a discount courtesy of
yours truly they make for some pretty
awesome presents and may just arrive by
christmas time depending on where you
are
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is mathenton abandoned
signing out
[Music]
you